>>> WE HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE CNN
INTERVIEW FOR YOU THIS MORNING,
A ONE ON ONE WITH HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER, KEVIN McCARTHY WHO IS
POISED TO POTENTIALLY BECOME
HOUSE SPEAKER IF REPUBLICANS WIN
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE TOMORROW.
MELANIE SAT DOWN WITH KEVIN
McCARTHY ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
WHAT DID HE TELL YOU ABOUT WHAT
A REPUBLICAN MAJORITY WAS GOING
TO LOOK LIKE, WHAT THEIR PLANS
ARE IF THEY DO WIN THE HOUSE
TOMORROW?
>> Reporter: I MET UP WITH THE
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER HERE ON
THE TEXAS BORDER WHERE HE IS
RALLYING FOR A NUMBER OF
HISPANIC REPUBLICAN WOMEN
CANDIDATES.
AND I STARTED BY ASKING HIM WHY
HE CHOSE TO BE HERE IN THE
CLOSING DAYS OF THE CAMPAIGN.
>> I COULD BE ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
BUT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
THESE ARE VERY COMPETITIVE
RACES.
MAYA FLORES, WHICH SHOCKED THE
WORLD, NO ONE THOUGHT SHE COULD
WIN THE SEAT AND WON IT IN THE
PRIMARY.
COMPETITIVE RACE.
SHE'S THE FIRST MEXICAN-BORN
WOMAN ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
MONICA DE LA CRUZ, CAME SO CLOSE
LAST TIME.
AND CASEY GARCIA, WHAT A TRIO OF
THREE LADIES THAT ARE
REMARKABLE.
WE WANT TO GIVE THEM ALL THE
SUPPORT THEY CAN.
THEY REPRESENT THE DISTRICT WELL
AND YOU SEE A CHANGE IN
DEMOGRAPHICS.
WHEN MAYA WON HER DISTRICT WAS
84% HISPANIC AND SHOWS
REPUBLICANS CAN COMPETE ANYWHERE
IN THE COUNTRY.
NOT ONLY IS THE PARTY EXPANDING
AND MOVING FORWARD.
THESE CANDIDATES I THINK WILL
INSPIRE SO MANY YOUNG WOMEN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THEY ERR GOING TO LOOK UP AND
SAY THAT COULD BE ME, I CAN GET
ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE MORE AND
MORE REPUBLICAN WOMEN FROM ALL
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS RUNNING
FOR CONGRESS.
>> ON THE BORDER, IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING, WHAT WILL YOU DO TO
SECURE THE BORDER?
>> A NUMBER OF THINGS.
STAY IN MEXICO, YOU HAVE TO
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
YOU HAVE TO STOP THE CARTEL'S
CONTROL OF THE BORDER.
YOU HAVE TO STOP FENTANYL FROM
COMING ACROSS.
FENTANYL WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT
IS A CHEMICAL OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
IT'S KILLING OUR NEXT
GENERATION.
IT'S THE NUMBER ONE KILLING OF
AMERICANS BETWEEN THE AGESO OF 8
AND 45.
THOSE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ENLIST TO DEFEND OUR NATION, THE
AGE THAT'S MOST PRODUCTIVE IN
THE WORKFORCE.
IT'S DESTROYING THIS NATION AS
COMING THROUGH THIS BORDER, THE
POISON FROM MEXICO INTO THE
CARTELS.
AND 300 AMERICANS ARE GOING TO
BE POISONED AND DIED TODAY.
300 TOMORROW.
>> HOW DO YOU STOP THAT?
>> THE WHITE HOUSE HAS DONE
NOTHING.
YOU DO IT A NUMBER OF WAYS, DO A
FRONTAL ATTACK OF CHINA TO STOP
IT FROM COMING.
YOU CONTROL THE BORDERS HERE.
YOU PROVIDE THE RESOURCES THE
BORDER AGENTS NEED.
BUT ALSO PROVIDE TO MAKE SURE
THE CARTELS AREN'T CONTROLLING
THE BORDER IN THE BACKGROUND.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PROVISIONS
WE HAVE THAT WE MOVE FORWARD ON.
AND THEN MAKE SURE THAT FENTANYL
IN TIME ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
MOVE IT YOU CAN PROSECUTE THEM
FOR THE DEATH PENALTY.
>> WILL THERE BE AN IMMIGRATION
BILL ON THE FLOOR IF THE
REPUBLICANS WIN THE HOUSE.
>> I THINK THE FIRST THING YOU
SEE IS A BILL TO CONTROL THE
BORDER, FIRST.
YOU HAVE ALMOST 2 MILLION PEOPLE
THIS YEAR ALONE COMING ACROSS.
BUT THE PART THAT HASN'T BEEN
WRITTEN ABOUT, WHEN I CAME HERE
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO IT'S THE
FIRST TIME IT GOT MENTIONED.
THE PEOPLE CATCHING ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST, THERE'S
BEEN 98.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET ON THAT.
WE CAUGHT THEM COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER THIS YEAR.
IN CALIFORNIA WE CAUGHT A NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS COMING FROM YEMEN
ON THE TERRORIST WATCH LIST.
THOSE ARE JUST THE ONES WE
CAUGHT.
WHAT ABOUT THE INDIVIDUALS WE
HAVE NOT CAUGHT THAT ARE ROAMING
THROUGH OUR COUNTRY.
>> TWO OTHER ISSUES THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE TALKED ABOUT,
CRIME AND INFLATION.
WHAT WOULD REPUBLICANS
SPECIFICALLY DO TO BRING THOSE
DOWN?
>> WE CAME OUT WITH A COMMITMENT
TO AMERICA.
FIRST THING WE'RE GOING TO DO IS
MAKE SURE AN ECONOMY THAT'S
STRONG.
>> WHAT SPECIFIC BILL WOULD THAT
BE?
>> WHY DO WE HAVE INFLATION,
RIGHT.
EVEN LARRY SUMMERS WARNED THE
DEMOCRATS NOT TO PASS THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN.
A BILLION DOLLARS OF HARDWORKING
TAXPAYER MONEY TO PRISONERS.
YOU HAVE TO CURTAIL GOVERNMENT
SPENDING.
THE NEXT THING YOU HAVE TO BRING
GREATER PRODUCTIVITY.
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO GO TO
WORK, NOT STAY HOME.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THE NEW
REGULATIONS ADDING TO INFLATION
ARE GETTING CURVED BACK.
AND MAKE SURE AMERICA IS ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
THAT IS A VERY BIG MARK TO START
WITH.
IT CREATES MORE AMERICAN JOBS,
MAKE US LESS DEPENDENT IN OTHER
AREAS BUT MAKES AMERICA STRONGER
AND HIGHER PAID.
AFTER WE GET DONE DOING THAT.
WE LOOK AT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE A
NATION IS SAFE.
ONE IS SECURING THE BORDER,
ANOTHER PROVISION IS NOT TO
DEFUND THE POLICE BUT FUND THE
POLICE.
WE'LL PROVIDE MORE GRANTS TO
GIVE MORE RECRUITING OPPORTUNITY
FOR OFFICERS TO COME AND TRAIN.
AND WE'LL LOOK AT ALL THE
PROSECUTORS TO SEE IF THEY'RE
PROSECUTING TO UPHOLD THE LAW.
WE FIND IN NEW YORK AND OREGON,
THEY WENT PROSECUTE.
WE HEARD THE DEVASTATION IN NEW
YORK OF A YOUNG WOMAN BEING
RAPED BY A SERIAL CRIMINAL,
ARRESTED 25 TIMES.
AND CREATE THAT TRAINING
THROUGHOUT.
>> AS ANOTHER POLICY ISSUE, THE
DEBT CEILING.
ARE YOU WILLING TO RISK A
DEFAULT USING THIS AS A
BARGAINING CHIP?
>> YOU DON'T RISK A DEFAULT.
>> NOT RAISING IT WOULD BE A
DEFAULT.
>> SIT AND PAUSE FOR ONE MOMENT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DEFAULT BUT
THINK FOR ONE MOMENT HERE.
>> UNDER YOUR WATCH THERE WOULD
BE NO DEFAULT HERE?
>> LET ME ANSWER THE QUESTION.
PEOPLE SAY YOU PUT IN A DEFAULT.
A DEBT CEILING IS YOU HIT A
LIMIT ON YOUR CREDIT CARD.
IF YOU GIVE A PERSON A HIGHER
LIMIT, WOULDN'T YOU FIRST SAY
YOU SHOULD CHANGE YOUR BEHAVIOR
SO YOU DON'T KEEP RAISING IT ALL
THE TIME.
I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
WASTE, FRAUD, AND ABUSE.
WASHINGTON HAS SO MUCH WASTEFUL
SPENDING WE CAN CURB THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD LOOK AT
FROM DAY ONE.
YOU SEE RIGHT AFTER THE ELECTION
NEXT WEEK I WILL COME OUT WITH A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS TO GET OUR
HOUSE IN ORDER FINANCIALLY AND
DO IT IN SMART MANNERS AND
REALLY LOOK ACROSS THE NATION,
NOT JUST INSIDE CONGRESS ITSELF
BUT SOME OF THE BRIGHTEST MINDS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT CAN HELP
US WITH THIS.
THOSE THAT HAVE TURNED AROUND
COMPANIES BEFORE.
HOW DO YOU ELIMINATE WASTE?
MORE PRODUCTIVITY.
HOW DO YOU ELIMINATE
DUPLICATION, YOU SHOULDN'T SAY
I'M GOING TO LET YOU KEEP
SPENDING MONEY.
>> REPUBLICANS DID RAISE THE
DEBT CEILING UNDER TRUMP.
>> AND THE DEMOCRATS SPENT
$10 TRILLION THAT GOT US INTO
THIS PROBLEM, HIT A DEBT
CEILING.
DO YOU WANT TO CONTINUE THAT
PATTERN?
DON'T YOU THINK IT'S A
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAXPAYERS THAT
WE CURB THAT, ELIMINATE WASTE,
ELIMINATE WHAT IS GOING ON ON
ALL THIS SPENDING AND THOSE ARE
THE THINGS WE'LL LOOK AT.
>> BESIDES LEGISLATION,
REPUBLICANS HAVE MADE
INVESTIGATIONS A HUGE PRIORITY.
YOU SAID NOT GOING TO DETERMINE
THE OUTCOME BUT IS IMPEACHMENT
ON THE TABLE?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S ON THE TABLE,
ACCOUNTABILITY.
SHOULDN'T WE KNOW WHERE THE
ORIGINS OF COVID STARTED?
WE DIDN'T HAVE ONE HEARING.
SHOULDN'T WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE LAST 60 DAYS OF
AFGHANISTAN SO WE WOULD NEVER
REPEAT THAT AGAIN.
WE VOWOULDN'T HAVE 13 NEW GOLD
STAR FAMILIES.
SHOULDN'T WE KNOW WHY THE DOJ
WOULD TAKE IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
GO AFTER PARENTS THAT WOULD GO
TO SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS.
SHOULDN'T WE KNOW WHERE THE
TAXPAYERS' MONEY IS BEING SPENT.
I CALL THAT ACCOUNTABILITY.
THAT'S A RESPONSIBILITY FOR
CONGRESS REGARDLESS OF WHOSE
EVER PARTY IS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> SOME OF YOUR MEMBERS ARE
CALLING FOR IMPEACHMENT, WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO THOSE MEMBERS?
>> ONE THING I'VE KNOWN ABOUT
THE LAND OF AMERICA, IT'S THE
RULE OF LAW.
AND WE WILL HOLD THE RULE OF LAW
AND WE WON'T PLAY POLITICS WITH
THIS.
WE'LL NEVER USE IMPEACHMENT FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IF SOMETHING
RISES TO THE OCCASION IT WOULD
NOT BE USED.
AT ANY OTHER TIME, IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF IT'S DEMOCRATS OR
REPUBLICANS.
BUT THE IDEA OF WHAT DEMOCRATS
HAVE DONE, WHAT ADAM SCHIFF HAS
DONE, TREACHEROUSY.
WHAT HE PUT US THROUGH, WE'RE
BETTER THAN THAT.
WE NEED TO GET OUR NATION BACK
ON TRACK.
THAT'S WHAT THE COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA DOES.
IT'S PLAN FOR A NEW DIRECTION,
AN ECONOMY THAT'S STRONG, A
NATION THAT IS SAFE, A FUTURE
BUILT ON FREEDOM AND A
GOVERNMENT THAT'S ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT IS OUR FOCUS.
>> MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE SAID
SHE WANTS A SEAT ON THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THAT?
WILL YOU SUPPORT THAT DESPITE
HER REMARKS AND DENYING THE
ELECTION.
>> IF SHE GETS ELECTED SHE HAS
COMMITTEES TO SERVE ON.
>> ON OVERSIGHT?
>> SHE'LL HAVE COMMITTEES TO
SERVE ON JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER
MEMBER.
AND EVERY MEMBER GOES THROUGH A
STEERING PLACE TO SEE THE BEST
PLACE TO SERVE.
>> YOU'RE ON THE STEERING
COMMITTEE, WOULD YOU SUPPORT HER
GOING TO OVERSIGHT?
>> I'M ONE PERSON.
>> IT HAS MORE WEIGHT.
>> BUT MARJORIE GREENE IS GOING
TO HAVE COMMITTEES.
SHE'S ELECTED BY HER DISTRICT.
>> YOU HAVE NO RED LINES IN
TERMS OF WHAT COMMITTEE SHE
GETS?
>> NO.
SHE CAN SERVE ON A COMMITTEE
LIKE ANY OTHER MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.